now six o'clock it is Friday morning a
pleasant good morning to you as you're
getting ready to get out the door
potentially this morning guys good
morning to you we've got a busy weekend
ahead we sure do I have a question where
did September go yeah I know I don't
know wake up Green Day because it's
ending oh my god
wow that was good I came out and it's
not planned no it wasn't okay
the month is gone we roll into October
tomorrow and it's gonna feel like it no
it doesn't but it still feels a little
summery we will have some summer-like
days as we finish off the month and head
into October this weekend so plan
accordingly just make sure that you're
keeping yourself hydrated and don't
forget the sunscreen if you're going to
be outdoors beautiful Skies this morning
we are a little drier so it feels even
better with temperatures above normal we
should really be in the mid 60s for
morning lows and instead we've got mid
to Upper 70s around the valley but
humidity is down 24 dew points are down
yesterday we were at 55 for the dew
point there was a lot of monsoon
moisture left over yesterday but we've
been drying out with the help of some
west southwest breezes not too Breezy
right now but we are warmer we hit 98
yesterday we should be 89 for the
afternoon High Sunrise officially 6 35
and 6 26 is the sunset so we'll be
warming back into those 80s mid-morning
and by the time you get to the lunch
hour we'll be already up to about 90
degrees we will get some of those west
southwest breezes again today and we
really should keep a lot of sunshine we
may see a high Cloud drift through but
we'll say sunny and drier as we get some
of those west southwest breezes maybe 15
20 miles an hour they got pretty bumpy
yesterday especially up Northwest of the
valley along U.S 95. it's going to be a
nice Friday but a warm one so be
prepared we'll check your weekend
forecast Nate's here with a look at the
drive let's check out the roads and the
commute already some problems yeah now
the freeways are okay so that is the
good news of the South 15's jamming up a
little bit out of the spaghetti Bowl but
that's kind of an everyday thing but we
have three crashes working off the
freeways first one's been around for a
couple of hours now and it is blocking
some Lanes in the Southeast Valley not
on the 95 515 but on Boulder Highway
between trop and Russell a street called
Whitney show you a live picture here
Metro Police tell us a car into a light
pole on this one that does not it almost
looks like a complete closure but
traffic is being allowed through but
very slow through that area they have
cleaned up a crash at Sahara and
Paradise however the traffic signals are
still flashing red here so be very
careful of course there's a Sahara Hotel
here and there's a kind of a parking lot
for the monorail and the other crash I
think it is mostly clear but there is
still a left left turn lane blockage on
Rancho at Vegas Drive John Heather very
busy morning 603 here on a Friday and it
was a shaky night up in North Las Vegas
and did you feel it in earthquake the
U.S Geological Survey says it was small
2.5 earthquake hit near Craig Ranch Park
in North Las Vegas it was about eight
o'clock last night we haven't received
any reports of damage it was small kind
of seems like only people living up
there in that North Las Vegas area
really felt it but if you did now you
know Clark County has identified one of
two victims of a large Centennial Hills
house fire last week her name Elizabeth
Dragon a man was killed as well his
identity though has not been released
Clark County Fire is still investigating
the cause Heather this morning some very
dramatic new video showing the exact
moment metro police arrested a convicted
murderer who'd escaped a medium security
prison near Indian Springs police say
Porfirio Duarte Herrera was just steps
away from boarding this shuttle to
Tijuana when officers swarmed the area
earlier he'd apparently been recognized
by the front desk dispatcher at the
transportation service company
she she played along she didn't like was
she wasn't obvious but then as soon as
she's finished checking him in for the
trip she went to the back offices and
just confirmed with the maksha that it's
truly incredible the service staff
members say portfolio Porfirio uh he
looked normal wearing jeans and a ball
cap even had an ID which was later
revealed to have a fake name the manager
of the transportation service says he
considers the dispatcher a hero for
calling police
another delay in the battery case
against New Orleans Saints running back
Alvin Kamara and three other men the
case has now been pushed to November
Metro Police say that attack happened
outside Dre's nightclub during NFL Pro
Bowl weekend inside the Cromwell lawyers
for the defendants have asked for more
time to try and resolve the case
gubernatorial candidate and current
Sheriff Joe Lombardo is walking back his
recent stance on abortion in Nevada the
Republican initially said if he wins
he'll repeal Governor sisalak's
executive order that protects
out-of-state patients and doctors
seeking Services here in our state he
says he originally thought the order was
political theater just a campaign tactic
now he says he would not repeal the
order until the legislature makes clear
that Nevada will not prosecute women or
providers over abortion 605 improvements
to Stewart Avenue yesterday Governor
sisalak joined the city of Las Vegas and
federal officials to announce a pretty
big project money from the recently
passed infrastructure bill will pay for
changes on a Four Mile stretch of road
once it provides you know some equity in
terms of how the infrastructure money is
being spent provides more safety and
comfort for this area this is a hot spot
area we're going to have 700 trees
planted we have bike Lanes
White House officials say 900 million
dollars from that infrastructure bill
will go to improve Nevada roads Bridges
and airports
606 here on a Friday morning tomorrow
Las Vegas marks five years since the
what October shooting and there are
events planned all weekend and starts
tonight on the Vegas strong resiliency
Center is urging you to take part in a
lantern ceremony it honors victims
survivors First Responders I'm Kenneth
Charles joining us now live from the
healing Garden this is just a beautiful
tradition Candace good morning
good morning Heather it really is and 2
000 people have already registered for
this event really speaking to how
everyone has been touched by